ser católico en Nicaragua en este tiempo
de disputa entre Daniel Ortega y la
iglesia es un riesgo el papel de algunos
religiosos en la defensa de Derechos
Humanos ha hecho que el gobierno
emprenda una guerra en contra de la
institución a la que considera mafiosa
una guerra que se siente con más fuerza
en semana santa las procesiones de días
pasados no fueron tan masivas como en
años anteriores por temor a represalias
el gobierno nicaragüense prohibió toda
manifestación de fe fuera de las
iglesias Entonces ahora Estamos
alrededor pero aún así el pueblo existe
asiste a la sangre de Cristo para mí lo
mismo A donde sea estamos con la con
Dios y con él pues que nos lleva un
poquito más adelante con fervor uno
siempre va adelante
si aún desea sea que nos pongan las
medidas que nos ponga Pero estamos bien
para Leopoldo brenes arzobispo del país
centroamericano el número de feligreses
no ha a pesar del asedio
totalmente llena el Papa Francisco ya
condenado la persecución a la iglesia
católica Nicaragua un país de mayoría
católica cerca del 75% de los
nicaragüenses profesa esa religión
estamos viendo tanto
la parroquia diferentes
han prohibido en la procesiones pero el
fervor del pueblo no lo van a vencer
Además del obispo Rolando Álvarez
crítico con el gobierno quien fue
condenado 26 años de prisión tras no
aceptar la orden de abandonar el país
por parte de Ortega el periodista
nicaragüense Víctor diccay fue detenido
este jueves por cubrir una procesión
según denunció la plataforma alertas
libertad de prensa Nicaragua